[Music]
Artie from Glee is played by an actor
who's this like incredible dancer which
feels very ironic to me I get it when
you're like casting a big name so that
the show or the movie is getting more
reviews or you have like a name behind
it but this kid I think was an unknown I
appreciate that the show is trying to
promote diversity by having a disabled
character like Artie but I think he
could have possibly been handled in a
little bit more of a sensitive way so
he's having some sort of like a dream of
sorts where he's dancing in the mall I
mean you can dance in a wheelchair I
think they were trying to show how much
he wants to be like how he was before he
became disabled and that's real but I
don't think portraying that through a
dance sequence where he's suddenly so
sad to be back in his chair again and
he's back to being disabled again I
don't think that is the right way to
show that I'm picturing every kid at
home who has a disability who watched
that and was like feeling like should I
be dreaming about not having this or
should I be wishing that I don't have
this instead of how do I love what makes
me me and I think it would have been a
lot more powerful to maybe show him
going through a arc or he reaches
self-acceptance and self-love rather
than trying to change his circumstances
you know he plays Diane wheelchair guy
and wheelchair wants to walk
oh what a shocking story art it doesn't
offend me anymore I just feel like it's
lazy writing if they had a writer or
maybe somebody there with the experience
that already has that scene would have
been treated differently hi Vicki
about Friday night sorry did it well I
kind of thought Becky was the band-aid
Becky was them being like we messed up
we messed up the first time around I
think any casting of any disabled actor
I am called for it I loved Becky from
Glee I love her she is a character with
Down syndrome Yuasa has Down syndrome in
real life and her character was dynamic
and funny and sometimes a [ __ ]
I loved that sometimes people with
disabilities are [ __ ] sometimes I'm a
[ __ ]
it just felt authentic and real I don't
think we should date if it because I'm
too intimidating yeah okay so this plays
into a whole nother thing whole nother
whole other doesn't matter people with
disabilities date but we don't always
have to date people with disabilities
Auggie I'm sorry but you're not the only
one who has bad days bad days do people
avoid touching you when a person that
really touches you do they call it the
plague so I just watched wonder and I
wanted to love it and I really struggled
with the movie I'm glad that they
validate the struggle of going through
an experience like disability that is so
isolating it's difficult feeling like an
outsider I remember being like please
give another kid the award please give
another kid the award we shouldn't just
be getting awards for basically living
our life I want a character Award when I
was in high school I was like what this
is sort of the same thing
yay you're different I don't know I
think it's a little bit tricky to have a
disabled character that gets like an
award because they're disabled but I
love that it's more because of the
courage and the heart that they have
inspiration part this is inspiration
porn
everyone's brave we're all doing things
that scare us disability or otherwise
like I am NOT to be pitied I'm here and
I'm hard to kill how's it coming in
there RJ Mitte oh good yeah for me
Walter
is a perfect example of a character that
represents the community he's an
incredible actor he's incredible and I
don't say an incredible actor with a
disability he's just an incredible actor
I was just really excited I remember
watching the show for the first time and
hearing about his being cast and that he
has cerebral palsy and I was very lousy
I've never seen this was the first actor
that I have seen of my age that I've
gotten to watched well there's this one
the pilot I remember this is a good
[Music]
thanks doc in a dressing room oh it's
the worst and I remember that too when I
first became an amputee like it wasn't
it wasn't like it was easily readily
available for me to get dressed or how
to figure it out how to get dressed this
is actually something that's similar to
happen you know with me in terms of
finding coats and stuff I don't know in
a tie-in it's super teeny tiny way it's
very very silly but I love that we have
similar hands somehow or we move
similarly I don't know I just think
that's very cool
you don't see that I don't know I don't
see that very much I don't know I would
just watch him and be like we moved
similarly we kind of would get through
similar situations it's validating it's
three dimensional we let's see this kid
as part of a family as part of his world
and his storyline again isn't just
disability this is gonna be fun Arnie
from What's Eating Gilbert Grape
Leonardo DiCaprio I loved this movie as
a kid but I rewatched as an adult and I
struggled with how they justified having
Leonardo DiCaprio play kid with a
disability well it's like watching old
World War two films that are completely
racist and you're just like wow the way
they represent this these group of
people and that it's insulting I do
agree I think it's definitely a product
of its time and I think we're still kind
of working on trying to figure out
what's like acceptable in terms of like
how should we cast
fools doctor said we'd be lucky if
Varney lived to be 10 doctor said we'd
be lucky if Arnie lived to be 10
it's clear that he's not gonna die by 10
so they like start the movie out with
some pretty big misconceptions people
assume disability means shorter lifespan
and I think things like this don't help
that narrative this characters sort of
served up on a platter for able-bodied
viewers of being like feel bad for this
family for having this kind of child I'm
guilty of being a dwarf you're not on
trial for being a dwarf oh I've been in
trial for that my entire life yeah
Tyrion Lannister that's the set I have
such a crush on this man such a crush on
this man there's a lot of things with
Tyrion I relate to it almost immediately
so so often we see little people being
cast in the role of like comedic the
comedy role
enough with the Lollipop Guild I love
that this is a drama that there's more
to his storyline
I love how intelligent he is and how
conniving he is and he's so funny that
is exactly the representation that
you're looking for that kind of validity
that kind of understanding of what a
community is going through that's the
thing that we're talking about so often
the storyline around someone with a
disability is disability like that's the
storyline and I think when they cast
someone who actually has a disability
almost always we get a more dynamic
story when I first became an amputee I'd
watch YouTube videos on above and below
knee amputees running or swimming and it
made me feel like I could have a life if
I could see someone who looks like me
and as an amputee that would mean the
world to me like that would be so
amazing like growing up I never really
had a movie like I remember there were
movies made about disabled people when I
was growing up Forrest Gump and then
hunched back and noted down those were
the only two that I remember we wanted
to be able to watch our stories and
relate to them and not sort of cringe
and go okay well this wasn't exactly
written for us it was written inspire
other people we want to be inspired we
want to be inspired by our own gifts and
our own talents and our own stories and
struggles and everything I was like you
know everybody else gets the privilege
to go to a movie and see themselves so I
think we're making great steps as of
right now but I think we can go a little
bit further in including more people
with disabilities in those stories